hey Dr Berg here in this video we're
going to answer a question from a client
who asked this drberg I'm trying all
these diets I'm eating healthy I'm
exercising it's still not working what
do I do help okay so we're going to
answer that question all right
so let me let me just I'm going to use
my book here this section we're going to
turn the
chapter turn to chapter nine which has
to do with the 10 fat burning triggers
and blockers
page6 okay so here's here's the thing
how can I put
this this is probably the most important
thing I can tell you and no one does
this in fact you're not going to find
this on the internet at all you can do a
Google search you're not going to find
it there's a just way too much
information and it's so buried you'll
never find it
um so if you're multitasking right now
if you're checked out I want 100% of
your attention CU this thing I want you
to ingrain this in your brain and write
it down but I never want you to forget
this in fact if I tell you this you have
to promise not to tell anyone this okay
it's just between you and me and the
four walls now I'm just doing this to
get your attention because
a lot of times people aren't fully 100%
listening when it's very very important
this thing is the most important thing
you ready all right so there's two
things or two situations that anyone can
do number one they can do certain things
and number two they can not do certain
things so we have
doing and not
doing all right and I'll explain
so these two actions like avoiding
certain
things these are not
equal not doing certain things is at
least
80% more important than
doing certain
things so the single most important
action is to put most of your time
effort and energy into avoiding certain
things and it's the first trigger
and it says the absence of sugar so let
me kind of give you a an illustration
here I did a seminar at curves once and
I'll never forget um it was a great
seminar had it was packed all these
people there they loved it they were
they were having sudden realizations
they were clapping applauding and um
giving a lot of great information until
halfway through this lady raises her
hand and she said Dr B this is very
interesting but how do we know you're
not a
quack and I'm like excuse me what I like
how she said it because she said how do
we like she's speaking for the group so
all my attention from that one little
comment went on this lady for the rest
of the seminar I completely got rid of
any positive thing from any person
because that one little negative thing
destroyed all the positive things that
was getting from that seminar so really
it's the little
things that make that can destroy a lot
of good there are six fat burning
hormones and there are three fat making
hormones but we're just going to talk
about two of them right
now these two hormones one is called
cortisol and the next one is called
insulin okay this is triggered by sugar
and this is triggered by
stress all right if these are in any
small amounts in your body it will
dominate and crush and destroy all the
good stuff that you're
doing these are things you have to avoid
these are the things that you have to
trigger so if you're eating good and
you're exercising and you're sleeping
and everything is great and you're like
99% there but you have too much of this
or too much of this you're not going to
see results especially if if you're in
your 50s now maybe it would work if
you're 18 because your hormones are
working but not as the um you get a
little bit older so the most important
thing to do is spend more time reducing
your body stress okay doing things to
reduce stress doing things to sleep more
doing things to avoid stressful
situations um and also doing things to
avoid sugar spending more time preparing
your meals for the week so you you don't
end up with Wednesday no food and and
have to eat some sugar uh avoiding
certain parties and things that you know
there's going to be sugar in there or
maybe eating before you came uh to the
party just to avoid this so it's much
much more important to eliminate
cravings and prepare for um the day so
you don't end up craving than it is to
eat healthy because I have this this
attitude that goes around there it's
kind of like um drbg I want to eat what
I want but I I'll just exercise harder
to burn out the more calories that won't
work or um everything in moderation you
know if I do it a little bit it'll be
fine but see that they don't know the
the importance of this versus that
they're putting way more attention on
things they have to do and they're not
putting up attention on these two things
okay so that is the
secret of how to lose weight when
nothing works okay as far as shift your
attention and your focus on this and I
promise you'll be way more successful I
hope that
helped